actually the orei were awesome and sg-1
series 9 and 10 were brilliant and
here's why welcome to sidetrack your
sci-fi tv a movie channel
[Music]
so matt did a video on tuesday telling
you why the ori is stupid but i'm here
to tell you that he is wrong and in no
small part because immediately at the
start of his video he said protagonist
instead of antagonist what an idiot who
would make that error new stargate
series i think i know the perfect
protagonist
welcome to sidetrack your sci-fi tv a
movie channel
yeah yeah okay
being forgotten about as quickly as
humanly possible i'm here to tell you
why actually the alright we're a great
villain and why those two series were
brilliant sg-1 for a start i was
actually really concerned when o'neill
left no more richard dean anderson in
stargate sacrilege but beau bridges came
in as the general and you know we had
ben browder as mitchell and they were
both really really good characters
other than it seems to have a rather
interesting if somewhat limited gene
pool
straight out of the box let's get into a
lot of what matt said about why the aura
were kind of stupid
there were a lot of reasons why the ori
character didn't really make sense
you know like like matt said we never
really saw them other than when um adria
finally um
ascended at the end and she returned as
a fully fledged aura with all of their
power
we didn't actually see them other than
to see a big wall of flames they always
talked through their priors
now i also actually the prize were
pretty cool i love the makeup i love the
episode and we're going to talk a bit
more about the episodes a bit later but
the episode where daniel became a prior
was just great gotta tell you though
not your look oh it is just temporary
really he talked about how though that
didn't really make sense and that how
this whole point about the origin and
the religion and how that the ori was
sort of like powered by the belief that
it was only by the belief of the people
in that galaxy that sort of allowed them
and like fed them well i've always
wondered if that was more of a metaphor
than literal but even if it was literal
we don't know how this works we're
talking about space magic you know
there's like there's no reason that how
that works or why that would work
but one of the points matt did make that
i completely disagree with was that
after we sort of met the uri they didn't
detect it they didn't understand the
stones then they alright didn't know
even though it was supposed to be all
powerful well i'd argue that i'm not
sure the all right were all powerful and
i've got a couple of reasons why
for one we know that the
ancients shielded us from the aura so
they alright caused the great plague
that wiped us out the ancients then
reseeded humanity and reseeded life in
the milky way and then the pegasus
galaxy
they then shielded from the all right i
would actually argue that we don't know
fully what happened there but i actually
wonder whether more than that we were
being shielded from the aura were the
uri fenced in so the ancients had
would believe to have unlimited power
but they never really wanted to
interfere with us lower life forms that
was kind of their philosophy but we
never really got to understand that in
any detail even though series 9 and 10
of stargate sg-1 we did get to see a lot
more about the ancients i really did
appreciate that there's there's lots of
things about the philosophy there's
things like the four horsemen episodes
where we found out about origin and the
great plague
um that taught us a lot more about the
ancients
but we still don't really understand why
they don't interfere we don't really
understand their power or their
knowledge as it were we don't really
understand how the ancients work so we
can't understand how the aura work
either so when daniel and vala appeared
using stone technology and then the ori
didn't detect them straight away
we don't know that the ancients would
have done either
but
as i said
we don't know that the aura weren't
actually fenced in
by the ancients rather than us just
being shielded because it would i think
suggest and there's evidence to suggest
that actually or i had stagnated quite a
lot two really good examples of this is
the technology they use so the super
gate now the super gate was freaking
awesome
but we were able to disable it
reasonably easily we were able to
disable the powers of the prize
relatively quickly if you think this is
a completely new technology a completely
new
enemy within a year of meeting them we
were able to find a way to disable the
ori technology using that little disc
thing that they planted the aura were
then never able to actually
counter that they never were able to get
their prior sort of up and running again
if we're going to hell
then you're coming with this
you go ahead and burst into flames if
you like
another thing is their staff to their
staff weapon it's very similar to gold
technology it doesn't seem to be much
more advanced so again
even the starships that they then built
the gate ships they were incredibly
powerful when we first came across them
but it was a new weapon and new
technology the asgard who yes we're very
very powerful and very advanced were
able to come up with a weapon system
that could be mounted on the deadliest
that was then able to defeat not just
one or a ship and straight combat but
multiple ships
[Music]
i'm not sure the or i were actually as
all-knowing or powerful as they led us
to believe
but there's a lot more than just the all
right in series 9 and 10 of stargate
sg-1
some of the other storylines i really
enjoyed was sort of like the development
of the jaffa nation i mean i know then
then got into the prize the prize
actually visited the jeff and tried to
make them their allies and tried to
bring them into the aura but one point
we did get to see a lot of that
infighting that happened the politics of
stargate which i always really enjoyed
and a development of a new nation um and
not a sweet happy rosy one like we would
probably would have seen a star game but
a warts and all version of what
something like this would actually look
like if it happened but the main reason
why stargate sg1 series 9 and 10 were
brilliant was the characters i've
already mentioned beau bridges i've
already mentioned ben browder
but really the character that i loved
the most
was valor claudia black's version of
valor was just great there are so many
funny bits in this series her
relationship with daniel in particular
was just gold all the way through you
didn't know well i knew it would make
you sick i didn't know it would have the
same effect on me too how could you not
no because the person that i stole it
from didn't tell me that part
she was a fantastic character she's kind
of sexy um but she also brought
something cheeky and new to the series
of tweet we haven't really seen in lots
of ways i always thought she sort of
replaced o'neill really and if there was
a straight replacement for her humor her
cheekiness and just just the way she
developed that character over the two
seasons and obviously then we've got
andrea
you're doing something new with your
eyes
[Music]
now marina is one of my favorite
actresses i think she's absolutely great
i think she's stunning and she was
brilliant in firefly i loved her in that
when she came over to stargate sg-1 i
was very excited
maybe i shouldn't use that word but i
just thought she's a brilliant actress
and she was just great in the series
she played it vulnerable at times but
also terrifying in others her
relationship with vala her mom was just
gold at times and then when we go into
after the series into the tv movie
that again showed a real dark side of
her but mourinho's acting chops when she
died at the end of series 10
was actually generally heartwarming as
well so she this is an actress that
really did have everything
and one other character that returned
for sg1 season 9 and 10 and actually was
in several episodes
well cliff simon's acting as the
character bar was again just great
especially when we started seeing the
genetic and copies of him and their
relation oh it's just fantastic so for
all of those reasons if you don't like
the all-right
fine they don't necessarily make sense
in lots of ways but
lots of sci-fi villains don't make sense
if you think about the gold wall don't
make sense a snake a massive snake goes
into the back of your head and wraps
around your neck and doesn't kill you
instantly does anyone know that the
spine is there where they go in
so that doesn't make sense there's lots
of things about it
darth vader and space wizardry in star
wars doesn't make sense
you know there's lots of examples of
this that you can nitpick and take apart
if you want to but it takes away from
the joy of the series and in this case
the series was just as good for me as
anything else stargate ever created
and i personally thought the aura were
awesome so guys get into the comments
tell me exactly what you think were they
all right awesome or stupid
i'd love to know exactly what you think
and at the end of the day who's right me
oh my if you are new to channel please
like and subscribe and hit the bell
notification it really really does help
us out and if you enjoy the content
please consider becoming a fully fledged
site tracker you can hit the join button
there
as always guys please stay safe i'll see
you next time
[Music]
you